so now we have some evidence in front of
us let's draw some conclusions shall we
uh we've already been banging on about
how there's this on domain and range
swamp right where you had I mean this is
a bit boring isn't it
domain and range are both all real
values right so domain and range for the
original are all real I should write
that domain actors for wheel values
range why is all real days okay so since
it's everywhere the inverse has the same
domain range okay what happens over here
well you've already been given this
restriction right so that's a domain
restriction here which becomes a range
restriction what is the range of the
original function the range of the
original function
rages up down doesn't it okay and this
is my original so it's greater than or
equal to negative one it does include
the boundary doesn't it okay so ratio Y
is greater than equal to negative one
which of course corresponds to the
domain of your inverse right the domain
is X is greater than or equal to minus
one negative one which of course makes
sense when you look at the square root
function so far so good
okay one last time let's have a look at
this guy the original domain yeah
X is greater than or equal to negative
one so let's have a look you actually is
it equal to do they exclude the boundary
they did exclude the matter of course
they exclude it because there's an
assitant right so we thought to exclude
it on the range about universe and the
range in the domain conversely not that
interesting you because again they go
everywhere okay so he's my first
geometric property that i want to note
geometric properties in an awesome ok
domain arrange swapped it sounds simple
doesn't it okay
but it's up it's easy to miss it's very
confusing sometimes you get confused
between domain of this domain to that
and so on okay
now then theme which i wanted to show
you which you can do very well but I
cannot do so much because my whiteboard
is stuck to the wall so I have drawn a
new one okay is it you can see there's a
pattern here is it visually you can see
what's going on okay these shapes when
you compare function and inverse
function function in inverse function
function an inverse function okay how
would you articulate express what's the
visual relationship between these it
might be a little easier if you turn
your head it's a reflection isn't what
kind of reflection isn't because as you
know we can reflect in lots of different
ways it's a reflection across a
particular line right namely y equals x
this is why I looked at this corner here
I asked you to work out what this
coordinate was you're gonna find it's um
the to the x and the y coordinate are
the same and of course you can see here
well it's the origin so that's good
okay but if you draw it away it goes X
which you should do it now you're going
to get this kind of line so if you twist
your head at 45 degrees because that's
the angle that y equals x forbs right
you're always gonna get this symmetry
and by the way this is how I knew that I
was only going to get one intercept over
here right okay now what I actually
suggest you do you don't have to turn
your head look at this thing
you can literally take your page and
turn it okay so now when you have it
like this just though how do you make a
reflection when you've got a shape think
back to when you do the transformations
translation and reflection and rotation
okay you would get a rule around right
he'd say look this is the line that I'm
reflecting across okay so you take a
point like like this one okay and you
get your rule up and you say okay I'm
going to go toward the line of
reflection and I'm going to form a
perpendicular line okay so let me see if
I can do this alright so you form a line
like that okay and you say alright how
far is this point that I'm reflecting
how far is it from the line that I'm
reflecting across and it might be
something like three centimeters right
so you're three centimeters this way
you're three centimeters the other way
you're pointing and eventually this is
let's say I better put a clip board up I
don't want to put the kind of mark on
the white board by accident you'll do
something like this let's try it shall
we and you should give it a go as well
hey guy turn it or 45 degrees okay so
this comes across here this distance so
there's my reflected point right this
comes across here there's my reflection
point there's gonna be your reflected
point up there right I could find
another reflective point over here
should be that distance okay and then
you connect the dots this guy
which sort of matches what you got there
get the idea you can actually see you
can actually see what that way
sorry you can see their reflection
because of the distances right and you
should do that in fear just so you can
make it obvious to yourself what's going
on